well you're employed now how's it feel
that's a big big weight off my shoulder
for sure you know I'm happy to be a part
of the team again and it's fun being
around these guys how did it play out
the last couple of months since we
talked how did it play out after that
where you eventually went to the CFL we
were going to give it probably around a
month after yeah I always said that you
know obviously the NFL is where you know
I saw myself playing so I stopped trying
to get back to but you know when that
that didn't happen I fully grasped what
was going on up here and wanted to make
this decision that helped I'm gonna come
up here I'm gonna come up here I'm gonna
be on time and I'm gonna get in here
with the rest of the guys be just
another one of those dudes that was the
the biggest thing for me was not slow
playing anything just hey this is what
my situation is this gives me the best
opportunity that further my career I'm
gonna go for it and listen at the end of
the day it gives me a chance to get back
if it gives me a chance to resume my
career you know I don't mind fighting
for what I want and our name I spotlight
and then you're committed to two years
so no matter how successful you are that
first year you can't go to the NFL a
team is interested in you is that
correct yes sir how familiar are you
with the Canadian Football League
I'm started watching a little bit last
year you know I watched their
championship game I was Simon Hamilton's
games last year when you don't have a
lot of time doing blowing like that and
you're just watching the NFL and you're
watching college football you know when
I throw the CFL stuff on there if that's
a possibility for I was gonna be so not
watch last year getting up here I feel
like I've got some of the majority of
the main rules down and that offenses is
you know just June's own system that
he's run forever and I think it's very
very interesting I think it's a good
game plan we have here what is a bigger
difference for you the the field being
wider 65 yards or the fact that there's
going to be 12 players on defense having
out there yeah right now the thing you
notice the most is the is the field
being wider because when you're trips or
to the field you know some of those
throws to the outside C or X or you know
definitely
you definitely have to get on the
majority or throws and really let it fly
that's one thing there is no real habla
the ball around here cuz there's so much
space you really step into him and let
it rip and I think that fits my my game
style a little bit as far as the 12th
you know the paper goes it just looks
different it's not as it's not what I'm
familiar to seen as far as you come up
and you look at your front foot defense
look at where your backers are things
are just a little bit off because
there's that extra guy but you know the
other day it's still ball four you're
still throwing the windows your snow
thrower out you're still throwing people
open I know you played in wind and cold
and Cleveland but this is a whole
different wind and cold up there in
Canada you're not in Texas anymore what
do you really night so obviously a
little bit further north and that's just
part of it you play an element you know
not every not every football stadium was
gonna have an indoor so you know you
playing the elements you play with
whatever the conditions are and you roll
with it so you know if you need some
things to do to help you know better
your chances of making a certain throw
or staying warm where you feel like you
need to be to be comfortable you know do
it and I feel like that's you know
that's how it's been any time I played
in a cold game her a little bit
different weather but it is not the
plains of West Texas or you know down in
College Station that's for sure he's a
Johnny Manziel the Hamilton tiger-cats
quarterback you're enlisted as are you
backup quarterback to Masoli Kellyanne
Oregon now back in 2009 2010 you know
the kid can play and he's been nothing
but a pro to me so far helped me with a
lot of stuff and really the progression
that I've made in a couple days is been
from watching him you know from the ones
and watching and learning from some
buddies who have been here has been it's
been a big key for me you almost went to
Oregon didn't you for really close and
the funny thing is no Chip Kelly is now
UCLA which is where I've been working
out pretty much all offseason so it's
funny how things he was infinitely
whenever I was coming out of the draft
we had a great talk and it's a confident
you know it's funny how those
relationships you made from college
coaches kind of mix and match and they
go all over the place
and you know cross the path with them
how close were you to signing with an
NFL team I know you worked out the
Chargers Patriots anybody else in there
in the you know you know we did that we
did a couple pro days that we did there
was there's a lot of eyes there but you
know like I was you know some of those
receivers Christian asked me if I want
to go to the one at am and and of course
that's a good opportunity for them and
beat it you know to help them with some
of the things that I've learned we in
Noe you know we worked out multiple
times it's helping him with his outs
what's what he's gonna be looking
forward to I going into a camp so you
know we had some talks a lot of it was
if he was like you need to be here you
need to be there did you do this do that
you know I pretty much followed
everything he had to say and you know
we've added a lot of coaches we've had a
lot of situations and opportunities and
and when it came down to it this was
this was the best opportunity that I had
on my plate without waiting longer and
potentially missing another follow
football because I cannot have it what
advice would you give Baker Mayfield you
know I feel like Baker's in a better
situation having a habit of that
quarterback in there and tie rod there's
not pressure on him to come in and start
day one and I think he's gonna go into
it and you know he's gonna learn from
the vets you know it hurts when you
don't have a guy like Joe Thomas you
know on the o-line because once I
started to get to know Joe and started
to pick his brain I really started to
learn a lot of stuff you know that guys
as a legend but there was that good
people around them he's got a great
group of receivers and trust in those
guys they have around I'm not be my
advice to him but you know Baker's got
the fire Baker's got the spark and you
know I think he'll do all right but but
don't let the pressure of everything
else that goes on you know gets you that
would be my one advice just go out and
make football the main thing and go out
and play like he's done for the last
five years if I told you five years ago
your futures in the Canadian Football
League
what would you said I would have said
you know there's no way that was gonna
happen
but when you make decisions I gotta made
in the past am i low points if when I
had continuously
betrayed the public trust people around
me who trusted in me and just betrayed
that you know it's hard getting back
into the mix of things and I sit back at
25 years old looking for the things idea
what I
21 as anybody might have and I'm
disappointed and upset with the
decisions I made but at the end of the
day you know I have a chance you know I
have life here to still continue my
career and still do what I want to do on
a football field now is that a little
bit different than what I thought sure
but at the end of the day I still have a
fighting chance
I still still am young I can still go
out and play and you know I'm gonna
fight and work my work my way back to
where I want to be and you know I know
it's a long road ahead but at the end of
the day I have a road you know there was
a point there in the password where
there was no road it was just cutting
through the woods so you know I feel
better to have a path today and have a
clear understanding of where I want so
how long I'm gonna be here and I'm back
around with the guys you seem older than
25 do you feel older than 25 I've been
through some stuff and there's no
denying that a lot of it was
self-inflicted you know a lot of it was
the craziness that came with the mania
of how my career at college career kind
of progressed but for now you know I'm
trying to temper those expectations I
know the media's gonna make it whatever
they're gonna make it and you know I've
shot a lot of that outs where I don't
see it I block it off and I focus not
what I need to be focused on and that's
learning his playbook as quick as
possible and learning out how to play
this game at a high level because it is
a little bit different if I said to you
if I only did this I'd still be in the
NFL right now what would you say all the
main things you know if I if I only you
know cut all the things that we're going
on off the field and just focus on
football and really put every bit of
time what weather or weather right now
without time and you know I'm still on
West Coast time when I wanna ever get to
sleep you know I don't have that luxury
right now yeah I could sleep or we're
into the season and we have you know an
off day or something I kind of want to
sleep when cams kind of over but for now
I'm behind I need to catch up so if I
would have done things like that to
where hey I don't understand that's all
the way
sit in there and learning who you do
understand it don't leave there's no
point to do anything else
there's no trips there's no luxury of
anything this game's hard and and the
people who are good at this game to put
in countless countless hours and then
translate for the guys who do play on
Sunday Saturday whatever it is go out to
play at a higher level
it's because they've done what they
needed to do
the week before in the time that you
know other people aren't working like
that you know the hard parts sometimes
with guys and when they you know they
want to stay clean or sober is that you
have to tell people who were your
friends or thought were your friends
that you can't hang out with them
anymore have you had to do that and of
course getting married too but you know
those guys call up and you know what
they're calling up for yeah I go she's a
life anybody else happy like you know I
think my main concern but listen there's
certain things I can't do those guys up
here that I'm sure talking about going
out and doing stuff but for me like I'm
here to play ball you know I'll get a
chance to relax and the season's over
you get a bye week or something like
that but for now like I said on behind I
have certain things that I have to do to
help me ensure success and that's you
know things also filled things in the
classroom things things you know that I
have to do to make sure I'm the best
person I could be when I'm a good person
and when I'm positive everyone you know
I'm doing all right
things seem to seem to happen you know
the right way for the most part I just
eliminate myself in negative situations
we were doing some research here you
being from Texas you're probably gonna
have to look for some barbecue Paulie
what did you find for Johnny and
Hamilton yeah John you're all set
southern smoke barbecue Ottawa Street in
Hamilton okay we got you set up by the
way you threw seven touchdown passes in
your NFL career do you know who you
through those touchdown passes to wait
you only had seven you should be able to
recount those I didn't get a chance to
play with JD as much as I would've
wanted to play with Jake year I would
have thought something that guy but you
know good times are the times that we
did win a couple games in house in
Cleveland I'll never forget it it is a
absolutely played apart I mean where I'm
at today for the better or for the worse
you know and I enjoyed my time there and
it didn't go the way that anybody
thought it would have I know that I know
it's disappointing but you know I feel
like we've all moved on they both on and
there's a point in time there where it's
probably a little salty and upset how
things went but for now you know I
listen the rest did you keep your Browns
Jersey all right all that stuff my dad
is a big collector and my stuff so all
my stuff a man that every home that I've
ever played and usually my dad is pretty
going to have that stuff at the house
you really enjoys it so we do have all
our stuff well you just made the CFL a
whole lot more interesting hopefully you
get some run there and saying all the
right things don't all the right things
we appreciate your time Johnny good luck
I always enjoyed it coming on with you
guys you're nothing but uh but I'm not
so I appreciate your time and I hope you
rest your day Johnny Manziel Hamilton
tiger-cats got a couple of weeks before
they get started
gonna be the backup quarterback there
got a chance and he needs to be there to
prove that he can do it on a daily basis
on and off the field and then maybe gets
another chance at age 27 with the NFL
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]